الحرب في اوكرانيا بين مد وجزر فتره تلوح
في الافق مؤشرات على امكانيه اللجوء الى
طاوله المفاوضات وتاره اخرى تظهر معطيات
تؤكد ان الصراع على زال مستمرا في اخر
التكهنات قال صحيفه جورنال ان الغرب لا
يرى غراء خيارا سوى الاستمرار في دعم
اوكرانيا مرجعت ان السبب الى قرارات
الرئيس
الذي اقنعه تصعيده معظم الدول الغربيه
بعدم وجود اي احتمال لاجراء محادثات سلام
قريبا
اه صحيفه عزيزه كلامها بتصريحات
دبلوماسيين غربيين مطلعين اكدوا ان واشنطن
وحلفائها لا يرون سوى احتماليه ضئيله
للتوصل الى نهايه تفوضيه للحرب في
اوكرانيا وسردت الصحيفه مجموعه من الاسباب
التي تجعل الخطوه الدبلوماسيه مستبعده في
الوقت الراهن اولها المعارك المستمره على
ارض الميدان سينا المعركه الوشيكه في
خرسون ثانيا الاستهداف الروسيه المتواصل
لمحطات الطاقه الاوكرانيه ما ادى الى
انقطاع الكهربائي في العديد من المناطق
وثالثها ضم روسيا لاربعه اقاليم في
اوكرانيا
لكن وبعد ان كشفت صحيفه وسط الجورنال ان
مستشار الامن القومي جيكسوليفان اجرا
محادثات لم يعلن عنها مع كبار المسؤولين
الروس على امل تقليل المخاطر في اوكرانيا
التي ربما تصل الى حد النزاع النووي ردت
روسيا على تلك الانباء ورفضت التعليق في
مقال المتحدث باسم الكرملين ان روسيا
منفتحه على المحادثات لكن كيف هي من ترفض
اجراءات تفاوض
وفي المقابل اوكرانيا رده ونفتت ما تدعيه
روسيا وافاد احد كبار المستشارين رئيس
الاوكراني على انك لم ترفض قط التفاوض مع
موسكو انها مستعده لاجراء محادثات مع رئيس
روسيا المستقبليه ولكن ليس الرئيس الحليم
العظيم ربوتن وكتب المستشار التابع للرئيس
الاوكرانيه ام ميخائيو بولياك على حساب
الرسميه على تويتر ان اوكرانيا لم ترفض
التفاوض فقط وان موقفها من التفاوض معروف
ومعلن مشددا على ان روسيا ينبغي عليها ان
تسحب قواتها من اوكرانيا اولا